[APPLAUSE]
DACHER KELTNER:
Thank you, Jessie.
One of the great privileges
of writing a book
is you get to go out
and speak to all kinds
of interesting audiences.
And I love coming to Google.
I should also let
you know that I
think a lot of the
thinking about what power
is in the 21st century, which
is at the heart of the book,
comes from experiences I've
had consulting here at Google
and working on projects
in Facebook and elsewhere.
So it's a great
privilege to be here
and to share this science
and these ideas with you.
I want to tell you
a brief story that I
came to when I was writing
the "Power Paradox"
that-- you're a young
audience, and it'll
be a little hard to imagine.
But I think you'll
appreciate this.
In 1970, my parents
did something
that no parent would
do in their right mind
today in today's
21st century, which
is my mom had just
gotten her PhD from UCLA,
and we were living in Laurel
Canyon, where the schools are
good and the kids are
healthy, and everybody's
going to college.
And it was a really
strong community,
as you might imagine from
that part of the world.
And she got a professor job at
Sacramento State University.
And so she moved us to the
foothills of the Sierras
in 1970, where we moved my
family to the poorest town
in probably the poorest county
in the state of California.
And I moved there
with my brother Rolph.
And in many ways, it was sort
of a Huck Finn, Mark Twain type
existence.
We had a pond and five acres
and ran around in the fields
and got into trouble
with my friends.
But I noticed something that
I couldn't make sense of it
in 1970 when I was 10 years old.
And I started to come
to make sense of it
when I wrote the book
"The Power Paradox," which
is that people in
my neighborhood,
although preternaturally
warm and kind and there
was always a spot
at the dinner table
and the parents were
working very hard,
the people of that
neighborhood were dying young.
If you start at
the top of the road
that I grew up on, where
there were only nine homes,
the first home on the right
looked like Appalachia.
The floorboards in
the kitchen were gone.
The dad was out of work.
The dad died really young.
The boy came over to our swing,
our rope swing in our backyard,
and dozens of kids
had jumped off
that rope swing
thousands of times.
And one of the first
times he jumped off it,
he landed funny on his arm.
His arm snapped in half.
We now know that
as something called
child frailty
syndrome that tends
to run in really poor families.
If you go across the
street there's this house,
and we never saw who
lived in that house.
It was like Boo Radley
in that famous book.
And I later learned that the guy
who lived there had something
called agoraphobia.
And I learned this
in graduate school
at Stanford, which is
the paralyzing anxiety
of going outdoors.
You go down two street
houses, it was my best friend
[? Memo ?] [? Compos ?].
His sister had leukemia.
His dad got cancer in
his 60s, killed himself
because he didn't want
to die a death of cancer.
Go a couple houses down,
there are three families
from Oklahoma.
One of the moms died in her 40s.
Another dad died in his 60s.
And when I grew up
in this neighborhood,
at the time I just thought,
this is my crazy neighborhood.
This is rural life.
This is Penryn, California.
And what I didn't
know and now we
know with increasing certainty,
with the science that I report
on in "The Power Paradox,"
is that these people
were dying because of the
effects of powerlessness,
that they were
marginalized in society.
As a very poor rural people,
no one went to college.
A lot of kids
ended up in prison.
And that force in
society was compromising
their nervous systems.
And what I'll talk to you about
is an intellectual journey
that finally got me to
some preliminary answers
to understanding why my
neighbors were suffering
such unusual fates.
And that's what I summarized
in "The Power Paradox."
It's really interesting.
As Jesse said, 25 years ago,
I'd been thinking and studying
power in every imaginable
context for the past 25 years.
And it's safe to
say, 25 years ago,
not only in the social
biological sciences,
but also in the
United States culture,
we were blind to
power differences.
We thought US
citizens, 25 years ago,
thought we lived in
a power-free society.
We're all middle class.
And we're all moving
fast up to the top.
That was kind of the
standard American myth
of the nature of hierarchy.
And if you look at the
social sciences, which
I was raised in,
of economic theory,
biological science, social
psychology and the like,
there was very little
systematic discussion of power.
Political scientists,
very interested in power.
Sociologists were
interested in social class.
But for the most
part, my discipline
had nothing to say about the
hierarchical dimension of life.
When I began this work, I
was struck by this quote
by Bertrand Russell
in 1938, when fascism
was on the rise in Europe.
And the great mathematician
said, "the fundamental concept
in social science is
power, just as energy
is the fundamental force
or concept in physics
that defines the relationships
between objects."
And he said that all
social relationships
are shaped by power as the
first principle of organization.
I didn't want to believe
that when I was a young guy.
I thought we would live in
a kind of an egalitarian
world of power-free dynamics.
Today we know this to
be fundamentally true,
that romantic partnerships--
many of you will have kids.
Jessie is soon to have a kid.
She's probably believing,
rather naively,
that this will be
pure love and freedom
and intimate
transcendent connection.
That's true.
But you are going to have
a lot of power struggles
with that person inside of you.
So we now know that a
lot of maternal diseases
are based on power struggles
between the developing
fetus and the mom.
They're competing
over resources that
predicts things like diabetes.
Bertrand Russell got it right.
And that really is what I
do in "The Power Paradox,"
is say, if this is the basic
medium, what are the laws?
What are the
principles of power?
And in the book, I provide
20 principles that really
relate to five questions.
What is power?
How do we get it?
How do we get it, be
it in US politics,
at Google, if you're
a seventh grader
and you're dealing with the
rawest of power politics, which
is the grammar
school playground?
In power dynamics with
your children and kids,
how do we get it?
Does power corrupt?
Regrettably, I think it corrupts
almost every human being.
What makes for strong
social systems?
I'll just give you a kind of
a glance at that thinking.
But things like
reputation really matter.
And then we return
to the thinking
of the social
biological sciences,
which is, how do we think about
the problems of today, right?
Syrian refugees, white
people in the United States
living shorter lives
than their parents
live-- white poor people--
the intractable problem
of poverty and that.
How do we think about it
through the lens of power?
And I'll tell you
some answers to that.
So what is power?
So when I dove into
the literature,
and this is a lot of smart
people writing about power,
the consensus would be
that power is force.
It's asymmetric force, right?
So historians write about power
as like we invent gunpowder
and we get this
asymmetric advantage.
In economic thinking, it's power
is really asymmetric capital
or asymmetric information.
You can think about it in
political science as force
through political
voice and the like.
And so there was this
sense in the literature
that powers might enforce
an advantage over others.
But that analysis doesn't
square with history or counter
examples.
So let me give you
two of my favorites
that are part tongue in cheek.
Take the average
American citizen
and think about who has more
influence over that person's
nervous system, Joe
Biden, our Vice President,
or Taylor Swift, the pop star?
Who do you think?
When I posed this question
recently to government
officials from Hong Kong, they
were like Joe Biden, like who?
Taylor Swift-- oh!
My daughter-- and
this is actually
a really serious point,
very relevant to the power
of Google, that power
scholars are making,
which is the idea of force as
power doesn't account for what
Joseph Nye at Harvard called
"soft power," which is today,
in our information-dense
world, the power of ideas
and art and the written word and
concepts stacks up very clearly
with the more traditional forms
of power-- who has capital?
Who has the biggest guns?
Soft power has
risen dramatically.
The idea that power is about
just about force and might
doesn't account for this
photograph right here.
These are my two daughters in
a younger state of existence.
We were in Zion National Park.
And you can do this
amazing bike ride in Zion.
It's eight miles.
There are no cars.
You go through the canyons.
It is sublime.
And being a psychologist,
I had this great scheme
because they were protesting,
and you'll learn about that.
I was like, all right,
for every 500 pedals,
I'll give you a handful of M&Ms.
So we're off.
Their faces are
covered in chocolate.
And I was like, no more M&M's.
And these are the facial
expressions that I encountered.
Who won that negotiation?
They did, right?
I mean, like, I was kidding.
Here are the keys to the car.
Have fun.
Credit cards on you.
But we are
necessarily, and really
a first task of the
book, and I hope
it's relevant to your guys'
thinking about the work
that you do, is
to really broaden
what we mean by power, right?
And I think, thanks to
the Googles and Facebooks
and Twitters and other forms of
technology, our sense of power,
the real action of power, has
broadened dramatically, right?
And so how I define
power is, and this really
dovetails with other
people, is power
is your capacity to alter
the state of another person.
The state of that
person could be
conceptual, knowledge, emotion.
It could be economic,
political, physical health.
It's about altering
the states of others.
When you broaden out
and you move away
from capital and military
might, you suddenly
have insight into how
history changes, right?
So these are some of
my favorite examples
that I write about in
"The Power Paradox."
This is incredible.
In the 17th century and 18th
century, 3/4 of the world
were slaves and literally,
technically slaves.
It was the central
economic structure
of the European economy is
slavery and the famous slave
trade.
Well, this guy right
here, Thomas Clarkson,
probably most of you don't know
about, was a college student,
and he wrote an essay.
He started hearing about
slavery, and he wrote an essay.
No one knew about slavery
at the time in Europe.
It won this contest.
He's 19 years old.
It gets passed on to
the abolitionists.
He then finds his way--
no Google searches--
to start finding information
about the nature of slavery.
He went to the docks
in England and learned
about the conditions
in the slave ships,
and then led a
political movement
that overturned slavery.
And 3/4 of the
world's population
changed and the economic
structures of the time--
from an essay, right?
We take a lot of pride in
the civil rights movement,
the free speech movement,
the protest movements that
flowed out of that
radical shifts in history,
when you think about it.
And it really can be
traced back to Ella Baker
and her organizing work that no
one knows about in the South.
That her basic
social influence led
to these important
political influences.
Here's another great one.
There is no more
significant influence
on human arrangements--
sexual arrangements-- probably
in human history,
I'm talking this
beats the bible and
any religious decree,
which was the invention
of the birth control pill.
The birth control pill was
led by Margaret Sanger.
She got this crazy
Harvard biologist
who got thrown out
of Harvard-- Pincus.
They started testing
hormones and its effects
on the cycle, led to the pill.
Before the pill, the
average American woman
had six children,
seven children.
It compromised her life
expectancy and her way
of being in the world.
After the pill, 2.3, right?
Radical shift by a
simple technology.
So when we broaden out
our definition of power,
we suddenly get all
this new insight
into how the world really
changes, right, as opposed
to just capital and the like.
Question two, how
do you get power?
It's one of these
age-old questions.
And when I started my research--
and it's interesting power.
How we get power
in organizations
like Google or
other places I teach
has changed in the last 30
or 40 years for the better.
You probably have a
lot of hypotheses why.
But when I started this
research 20 or 30 years ago,
and I'd pose the question,
how do you get power,
people were like,
oh, I got the answer.
It's the Machiavellian
answer of it's
better to be what than what?
It's better to be feared than
loved-- classic Machiavellian
phrase.
That's Niccolo Machiavelli.
He has a rather
mischievous-looking smile,
if you carefully analyze it.
He looks a little
bit like he's pulling
the wool over people's eyes.
And there's some question
about the intentions
of his intellectual work.
Has anybody read "The Prince?"
Excellent.
That's amazing.
And that attests
to Wikipedia, when
I checked this,
when I wrote this,
ranks "The Prince" as like
the 32nd most influential book
in human history.
It's probably the
most influential book
on power ever written.
It was bedside
reading of Mussolini.
Hitler was very much
influenced by it.
Shakespeare had
characters that were
built on "The Prince,"
almost a contemporary of him.
There are major schools of
political thought in the United
States-- I will
not tell you who--
who adhere to a Machiavelli
philosophy of power,
how you get power.
And that philosophy--
and it's worth
a little historical context.
Machiavelli wrote "The Prince."
He was a Florentine politician.
He got kicked out when the
Medicis returned and was
isolated in his
second home, and wrote
"The Prince" after visiting
his mistress every day.
And it is-- some
books, a lot of books,
are useful during a
particular historical period
and outlive their reason.
And Machiavelli's Italy--
I suspect a lot of you
have been to Italy, and
it's this beautiful place,
where rolling hills and medieval
villages, and you drink wine,
and you feel more kind-hearted
and loving than you've ever
felt in your life.
During Machiavelli's period,
historians rank Italy,
it's probably the most
violent place that
ever existed in human history.
It would put the
Mexican drug cartels
to shame in terms of just
raw violence and power.
And it's a theory of how you get
power in very violent settings.
Here are some random
contemporary translations
of power from the
Machiavellian perspective.
This is from a bestselling book.
Law number three,
conceal your intentions.
Law number six, court
attention at all costs.
Make sure everybody you lead
is always thinking about you.
Law number 12, use selective
honesty and generosity
to disarm your victims, right?
Sort of, use goodness
to-- and then,
what the heck, law number
15, crush everything totally,
right?
And this is a massively
influential theory
of how you get power.
There are Machiavellians
everywhere I go.
They're usually about one
out of eight or 10 people.
For a little extra
money, I can tell you
who's a Machiavellian in
your midst, but I'm kidding.
But in general, it fails today.
And I spend time in "The Power
Paradox" talking about this.
There's a pretty deep
literature on this
I got a little obsessed with.
I have a whole unpublished
chapter on this.
It tends to be a strategy people
prefer who are disenfranchised
in social networks.
Like I feel on the
outs, I endorse
Machiavellian
strategies, which kind of
makes you wonder about
American politics.
It will work in a
really violent contexts,
and it does work a little
in short-term interactions.
If I get together with a
group, and I'm manipulating
and I'm deceptive and
I'm pitting people
against each other, and
behind people [INAUDIBLE],
I'm like putting other people
down, I'll gain a little.
I'll be noticed and
have some influence.
But over time, people
catch on to you.
And then there are all sorts
of data showing that it fails.
The most basic and
relevant to you
is we can find Machiavellians.
We measure them.
And when you look at how they're
doing, they're not doing well.
They don't have status.
They don't have power.
They're on the outs
in social networks.
They are not happy.
They're paid less.
They have a lower rank.
We did a study,
recently published,
where we coded the social
strategies of US senators
from their C-SPAN
registered speeches.
We actually coded their
non-verbal behavior.
And you can identify, if
you look carefully enough,
Machiavellians who actually
laugh at people's suffering
rather explicitly.
They're like, those poor
immigrants, ha, ha, ha, ha.
We can code narcissism by
facial expressions that
show a lot of self-love, that
might remind you of today's
political candidates.
Here's one we identified.
Narcissism looks like--
[LAUGHTER]
I kid you not.
Then when that candidate
came became popular,
I was like, oh my god.
And what we find is
Machiavellian narcissists get
disrespected by their
peers in the Senate
and get less support for
the bills they advocate.
The senators who are more
courageous and humane
get greater support.
This is really interesting.
Historians are now
analyzing protest movements.
Some protest movements
are really Machiavellian.
They're violent and
have dramatic forms
of torture and the like.
Others are more
collaborative, build up
big audiences, gatherings
in the streets.
And the more collaborative
ones are much more
likely to gain power across
cultures in historical context.
So this philosophy, I really
feel, and a lot of historians
agree, is trending downward
as a means of influence.
So how do we get influence?
And this is where the
little bit of Berkeley
suffuses my thinking.
I apologize.
But very simply, and I'll
give you a few examples,
we get power by advancing
the greater good.
That your ability to have
enduring influence in the world
is most directly
dependent on advancing
the welfare of social networks.
Hannah Arendt, who's a brilliant
philosopher, who came out--
and some of her
writings, controversial,
are some of the best on power.
And she saw it firsthand.
She was in Germany, interviewed
and interrogated by the SS,
lost family, moved
to the United States,
knew about authoritarianism,
went through the McCarthy era.
She said, look, your
power is in your ability
to stir your social network.
And I think that
nailed it in terms
of how you gain and keep power.
So as a social psychologist,
I'm interested in, well,
what are the face-to-face
things you can do that advance
the interests of others?
And I'll just show
you a few things that
may seem
counter-intuitive, but I
could bore you with the
data that support this.
People who share resources
rise in social networks.
It's now replicated
a lot of contexts.
Mike Norton at Harvard
is working on that.
People who are really
good listeners,
and I'll show you some data,
are very good at keeping power.
People who routinely
spread gratitude,
tell good stories gain in the
ranks of the organizations
that they work in.
So a couple of findings that are
relevant to this-- this really
says it all-- Abe Lincoln
is ranked as our greatest
president with the
most enduring legacy,
and he was an unusual
guy-- didn't come
from a fancy background,
poor, really tall,
wore funny clothes.
Historians are kind
of pondering why
he had such a profound
influence compared
to his rivals of the day.
And Thurlow Weed, who was
a journalist at the time,
really got it right that,
and I love this phrase,
"he sees all who goes there,
hears all they have to say,
talks freely with everybody,
and reads whatever's
written to him" He was a genius
at knowing other people's minds
and just always gathering
out information and guiding
the complicated politics
he navigated through.
Charles Darwin, the most
influential scientist
in human history, same
thing-- he compulsively
was interested in what
other people thought.
And most of his
great insights came
from learning from other people.
He learned about evolution from
working-class pigeon breeders,
who most people
wouldn't talk to.
He went out and discovered
they were experimenting
in natural selection.
So this as a little side note.
So one way we gain power is
just respecting and embracing
other people's emotions.
Who here is in a
management position?
I've taught thousands
and thousands
of managers, and the surprising
thing about management--
what's the hardest
part of your job?
Other people, right?
Suddenly, you're a
manager and it's like,
wow, they're telling you about
all the problems in their lives
and all the stresses at work.
Maybe not at Google.
But it's just part of life.
And so one part of the
empathetic way to power
is something that
I had the privilege
of being part of is what is
revealed in this great film
"Inside Out" at Pixar.
I was a scientific
consultant on it
with Pete Doctor the director.
The central message,
the wisdom--
you should be listening,
Jessie-- of these two parents,
because you will indeed have a
pre-teen some day in your life,
is they just embrace
the hard stuff
and they're empathetic, right?
They take on the tough
stuff of Riley's life.
When I asked Berkeley undergrads
what they thought of "Inside
Out" last year, when we
were talking about it
in my emotion class, I have
this student who's a veteran.
He was homeless.
He's a brilliant guy.
He's going to med school now.
He's got piercing
all over, tattoos.
He raises his hand.
He's like, it was the darkest
film I've ever seen in my life,
man.
And the great thing
about these parents,
with some little
glitches here and there,
is they kind of embrace hard
stuff, like fear and sadness.
And we know if you're
empathetic, work
by James Gross at
Stanford, elsewhere,
even just like saying,
wow, this is a fearful time
or this is uncertain,
calms people down
just through various interesting
processes in the brain.
Just being empathetic
calms people down.
We know that if
you are mindfully
accepting of difficult,
stressful times,
in this particular graph, you
yourself feel less stress,
the more that you're just
embracing stresses of life.
And you also show a
better immune profile
in the inflammation response.
So empathy is part
of gaining power.
A couple final points on gaining
power, this pro-social side
to it, this sums up a lot of
the thinking about how good acts
in organizations actually,
perhaps counter-intuitively,
get you power.
And I'm happy to take
questions on this.
And it really
summarizes this big part
of "The Power Paradox."
Let me work through a
little diagram here.
So imagine at work
here at Google,
Maria expresses
gratitude to Samir.
She's like, thanks for helping
me out on that project.
Well, what we know,
which is fascinating,
is pro-social acts, like
gratitude, sharing resources,
giving your time,
cooperating with others,
actually activates,
in separate studies,
a very important
region of your brain,
the reward circuit, that starts
in the ventral tegmental,
produces dopamine.
That dopamine projects
to your prefrontal cortex
and helps you do things
in the environment.
What's remarkable
is the brain is
wired to make us
feel good about doing
good things for other people.
That to me, that's stunning.
But then the story
continues, which
is if Maria's
expressing gratitude,
she takes delight in
this pro-social act.
And then we know, work by
Nicholas Christakis and James
Fowler and others, if
Samir has been appreciated,
in his next interaction, he's
going to be more cooperative.
And there are amazing
studies showing
if I am generous
to Jessie, she's
19% more generous in
her next interaction.
And then those people
are 7% more generous
in their next
interaction, right?
Good stuff spreads
much more virally
through social networks
than bad stuff,
producing greater pro-sociality.
And then I have a section
in "The Power Paradox"
about how we develop really
positive reputations.
Your power is only as
good as your reputation.
We spend a lot of
money on things
that relate to our reputation.
And your reputation is rooted
in are you producing good things
for the group, right?
Are you not undermining people?
Are you advancing the
welfare of others?
And then that process of
having a good reputation
leads to other people
thinking highly of Maria.
And that motivates subsequent
pro-social behavior.
It's this amazing cycle
that promotes your power.
Now, I've tested these
ideas in different ways
in lab studies and the like.
And one of the ways
in which I tested
this to see if kind
of pro-social acts
makes teams better and
you enjoy better power
is with a rather
strange experiment
we did on the National
Basketball Association.
It's not really an experiment.
It was a study.
And whether really doing
encouraging forms of touch,
encouraging people
for their good play,
makes teams better players.
So I've always marvelled-- do
I have any pick-up basketball
players in the room?
Any former basketball players?
Good.
At least two-- I
knew you would be.
Of course you are.
So basketball's
this amazing sport.
By the way, statistics
are much more complicated
than baseball statistics.
Don't let people-- it's five
interdependent bodies, so
a very complicated thing.
And I've always
marveled at this thing
that I started
thinking about, which
is basketball is very
aggressive and it's physical,
and it really breaks
down your body
because you're crashing into
big people all the time.
And I tallied it up
one day, and I'm like,
I've played 3,000 pick-up
basketball games, from France
to the projects of
Brockton, Massachusetts,
to Berkeley, California,
and I've never
seen anybody hit
each other or fight.
I'm like, that's more peaceful
than the average family
reunion in America.
It's more peaceful than
shopping at Berkeley Bowl, where
vegans go.
And I saw two guys
with ponytails
get in a fist fight
over some vegetables.
I'm like, come on.
And I go, well,
how could that be?
And it's because of
the language of touch.
That touch builds cooperation
where competition really
should be pronounced.
And it's a way in which
we promote better behavior
and so forth.
So we did a crazy study.
This was Michael Krauss,
now at Yale, and I,
and a very devoted
team of coders
spent six months coding one
game of every team in the NBA
for how much the teammates
touched each other.
And this is what we observed.
And you could do this here
at Google-- high fives, fist
bumps, arm embraces, bear hugs.
Men like to hit each
other in the head
when they say good job,
and it's a mystery.
So those are two of
the greatest teammates
in basketball history, Tim
Duncan and Tony Parker.
He's rapping him in the head--
arm embraces, chest bumps,
flying hip bumps.
And if everything's
going amazingly well
and you write that great code
or do that great data analysis,
you fly through the
air and chest bump.
And I hope you guys
are doing this at work.
And what we found is two things.
The more teams did this stuff
at the beginning of the season,
the better they played
at the end of the season.
And then we could chart
how individual players were
these most valuable touchers.
They're the great touchers,
encouraging, fist-bumping
and the like.
And they actually,
through certain analyses,
made their teammates
play better just
by directing this very important
resource of touch to others.
So lest you think that
the idea that we get power
by being good-- it's more
true in the 21st century
than it was 50 years ago, a
lot of broad survey data show.
But this is actually a
surprising and robust
human universal.
Christopher Boehm at USC has
summarized 48 separate studies.
They're where
anthropologists go and live
with hunter-gatherer
societies or foragers.
They're living in
the small conditioned
groups in which we evolved.
And then the idea is
like who gains power
in those very tightly
organized groups that
really are the
conditions in which we
evolved for 200,000 years?
And across continents you
see this regular pattern.
And here is his summary--
that the leaders
are generous, brave,
wise, apt at resolving
conflicts, good speakers, fair,
impartial, tactful, morally
upright.
They're also strong, of course.
And they're humble,
right-- being good.
And by the way, if you're a
Machiavellian and screwing
people over in the
hunter-gatherer society,
it was very common-- the
group would get your relatives
to exile you or kill you.
We did not have the
luxury of that sort
of destructive
behavior for the group.
Power-- we get power by empathy,
by being good to others.
And now we buy into why I called
the book "The Power Paradox,"
which is that power unleashes
the more problematic stuff
of human behavior.
As Lord Acton said, power
corrupts, and absolute power
corrupts absolutely.
He was a 19th century historian,
critic of the Catholic Church
and all of its abuses,
and really questioned
authority-based structures.
You could devote a column
in "The New York Times"
to the abuses of power,
and you would have
new material every day, right?
Roger, the Fox guy, Roger Ailes,
what happened at UC Berkeley.
It just goes on and on-- the
regrettably named Anthony
Weiner.
Like, oh, again?
Whatever he does.
So it is a reliable
tendency in human behavior.
And I'm going to argue it
has massive social costs.
It's not just entertainment.
It's not just something
we make fun of.
There's a lot of cost at
the organizational level.
Let me give you a couple of
examples of how power corrupts.
We know, if you feel powerful,
you're more likely to gamble,
take risks.
Studies by Christine
Porath show that 3/4
of the rude, uncivil
acts in organizations
come from the powerful.
They're the ones who
are swearing at people,
leaving trash, expecting
someone else to-- these
are her observations--
someone else picks it up.
Even in very civil
organizations,
it produces rudeness.
This is a stunning one.
Somebody sent me this paper
when they heard about our work.
Who is more likely to shoplift,
wealthy kids or poor kids?
Wealthy kids.
Who's more likely to shoplift?
White people or people
of minority backgrounds?
White people.
That blew me away.
We think about who we
think is shoplifting.
It's actually the
wealthier whiter kids
who are shoplifting.
They have the money to pay
for it, but they're doing it.
Here's a study we did early in
this story of power corrupts.
We brought people to the lab.
We had them do something that
was by design really boring.
They had to write policies
for the university they're at,
which is my job.
It was a little act of
rebellion on my part.
So they're writing away.
There are three people.
We randomly assigned one person
to the position of power.
And they're writing away.
And halfway into the study, this
is the key part of the study,
we put down a plate of
chocolate chip cookies.
Everybody grabs one.
Cookie, they eat it.
OK, I feel better.
There's one last cookie.
Who takes that last cookie?
Indeed, the
high-powered person's
much more likely to
take that last cookie
than the low-powered people.
We code how they ate.
High-power people are
more likely to eat
with their mouths
open, lip smacking,
and crumbs falling all
over their sweaters.
And I'm hoping my face
is clean, by the way.
So we did another study.
You may have heard
about this one.
It's gotten a lot of press.
It is my great graduate student,
now at Irvine, Paul Piff.
We wanted to know who's more
likely to drive in an impulsive
out-of-control way-- high-power
people or low-power people?
So here's what we did.
Don't take this
personally if this-- it's
a very sophisticated thing.
We have this very complex
quantitative scale
of how powerful your car is.
There is the Dodge
Colt from the '80s.
There's a Ford Taurus,
which gets a 2.
There's the middle, very
middle-of-the-road Honda Civic,
very aptly named.
There's a Honda Accord, I think.
And that's a very
fancy Mercedes.
And so what we did, we did
a variety of these studies.
We got a Berkeley undergrad,
and he stood right
at the edge of a
pedestrian zone, which is
that series of white stripes.
It's California
law that cars have
to stop for a pedestrian
in the pedestrian zone.
A lot of people get killed in
pedestrian zones in California.
It's a very dangerous place.
So our poor Berkeley
undergrad stopped and looked
at oncoming traffic.
And he looked like he wanted
to get across the street.
And we waited until
there's only one car
coming toward the
pedestrian zone.
And our question was, who's
more likely to violate the law
and almost injure this guy,
wealthy cars or poor cars?
Here's our data.
Indeed, if you're driving a poor
car, you always stop, right?
And I've been there.
Partially, it's because
it's like, oh, god,
I've got that bad tail light.
I wonder if someone's
going to catch me.
But if you're driving a
fancy car, 46% of the time,
people blaze through the zone.
People emailed all
kinds of questions.
Audi called us up.
What about Audis?
We did a data analysis--
not sufficient sample size.
But they're actually
pretty good drivers.
And then we got the next
one, what about the Prius?
I'm sure a Prius is a fancy
car, but in actuality, Priuses
were the worst drivers
and offenders of all.
I apologize.
So there we go.
And then there are a
lot of studies showing
that power makes us lose our
ability to take other people's
perspectives, to empathize.
This study by Adam
Galinsky and Joan McGee,
you're either put
into a position
of low power or high power.
And you just have to draw
an E on your forehead
so the person sitting
across from you can read it.
So you have to flip your
usual way of drawing it
and draw it in reverse-- take
other people's perspectives.
Easy to do for
low-power people, harder
to do on the right for
high-powered people.
So that's "The Power
Paradox," and then I'm
going to give you three
or four minutes of data
on where I began this
journey with the neighborhood
that I grew up in.
The power paradox
is really striking.
I actually think it's
the most important thing
you have to solve in
your life is to not fall
victim-- you guys are young.
You will have a lot
of power in your life,
over people at work, your
kids, your partners, members
of your community.
And this is the central
dynamic of do you become
seduced by your own power?
The power paradox is groups
want really socially intelligent
people to lead the groups.
That's why we rise through
social intelligence.
Power decreases
those capacities.
We gain power
through what is good.
And then a lot of
the bad stuff we
read about in human
history, abuses in churches,
excessive military moves, the
Holocaust, are abuses of power.
So we can bring this up.
I have less data on this.
This is how you design social
systems to make them less
vulnerable to these abuses.
Things like collective
scrutiny, accountability
all diminish the
tendency to abuse power.
Strong ties, things
that Google does,
actually diminish
the abuses of power.
But here's where I
want to end, which
is how thinking about
power and powerlessness
helps us think
about, I think it's
the central problem in the
United States society today,
and in part because
for while we are
in such a strange political
season, the strangest in my 36
years of voting, so it
has to do with this.
You know, I hope, that
we are at historic levels
of economic inequality
in the United States.
Although that's shifted
ever so slightly
in the last wave
of economic data.
You know that one out
of five American kids
is raised in poverty,
where the average family
income is $23,000 a year.
We have students
at UC Berkeley--
we have a lot of poor
students at Berkeley,
which I'm proud of, who
have hunger problems.
We did a big survey.
A lot of our students
are not eating regularly
because they don't
have enough money.
And so we're working on that.
It's endemic to our culture.
And this is, I think, one of
the most important branches
of the social
biological sciences.
This is your stress system, the
hypothalamic pituitary adrenal
axis.
When you see danger
in the world,
the amygdala triggers act as
a signal to the hypothalamus,
goes to the pituitary
glands, drops
down to your adrenal
glands, which then secretes
and release cortisol
into your bloodstream.
You've heard of cortisol.
It's the stress hormone.
And when you have
a lot of cortisol,
you can code until
5:00 AM, no trouble.
You're at peak fitness in
terms of highly metabolically
demanding activities.
It's for fight or flight, right?
And then we started to learn
that chronic cortisol is
one of the worst
conditions for your body.
It prematurely ages you.
So here is where powerless
comes into the equation.
There are these
studies first showing
the single biggest predictor
of cortisol release
in your body is not spiders
or the saber-tooth tiger
out there.
It's feeling disempowered.
It's feeling like others
are threatening you
in a dominant fashion, right?
It's when you're being
lowered by other people.
That is amazing to me.
A system that helped
us flee predators
in our evolutionary
past is really
about power dynamics today.
So we know, for example,
if I'm African American
and I hear racist words, it
activates the stress response
and cortisol release.
We know from empirical
studies, if I'm a woman
and I hear sexist jokes, that
activates cortisol release
and the stress response.
Rudy Mendoza Denton
has done studies.
If you're a poor kid and
you go to Columbia, where
most students are wealthy,
you'll feel this class dynamic,
and that activates
chronic levels
of cortisol in your bloodstream
because you feel lower
than others.
Sexual identity.
Jenn Lerner, my former
student, now at Harvard,
studied managers.
And if you're a manager and
you have a lot of power,
but you don't have respect
from the organization,
they don't let you
do direct reports,
you have elevated cortisol.
So the lesson is when
I'm disempowered,
I become hyper-stressed
and cortisol.
And then there are
new data showing
that this part of
our inflammation
response, the cytokine
response, these
are little proteins that
attack pathogens in your cells,
the common pathway
to most diseases
today is hyper-activated by
powerlessness, by poverty,
and feeling shamed
by other people.
Powerlessness is a tremendous
threat to our health.
And these are just
some of the effects.
This is Greg Miller and
Edith Chen at Northwestern.
If I'm raised for five years in
the powerlessness environments
of poverty, I have elevated
cortisol and cytokines,
and a 20% to 40% chance
of dying from disease
raised by five
years of that life--
very serious issues
to be taken on.
Part of why I find this
uplifting in an odd way
is what that tells us is
if we can empower people,
you can solve health
problems, right,
just by shifts in
their nervous system.
And so at my lab in
Berkeley, with Stacey Barrett
at the Sierra Club, we're
getting inner city kids
from Oakland and
Richmond and veterans
out rafting where
they feel empowered,
and they do the rapids,
and they wipe out.
And their nervous systems look
better at the end of the trip,
and a lot of interesting
interventions from there.
We're in a radical time of
shifting power dynamics.
We are emerging out
of serious hierarchy.
And that really has been
around for about 12,000 years.
When you step back and
think of it historically,
we're in a very serious
power revolution,
which is really interesting.
Women have more power today than
they've had in 12,000 years.
And the trajectory
is like that, right?
People of different
ethnicities, the power dynamics
at the national level, and
then the information revolution
is certainly important.
It's a really exciting time
to be thinking about power.
You guys are a very important
part of that revolution.
So it's a privilege to talk
to you about this work.
And I hope you make the
most of all the power
you will have in your life.
and do good for the world.
So thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 2: Thanks.
We have a question
from the live stream.
So someone wrote
in and said, you
said that more
powerful people flaunt
the law more-- so white
wealthy shoplifters,
nice cars blowing
through intersections.
How much of that
can be attributed
to not power but the ability
to afford the consequences
or knowing there will
be no consequences?
So a poor person cannot afford
the fine that they probably
will get.
A powerful person can
probably afford the fine
they probably will not get.
DACHER KELTNER:
Yeah, I think one
of the shortcomings
of psychology
and my analysis
is we don't think
about the deep systemic context.
And that's really true.
It's like in Michael Lewis's
"The Big Short," who's
a good friend, and you
think about the trillions
of dollars that were
lost and the hundreds
and hundreds of millions of
dollars that some people got.
And there were
problematic behaviors,
and no one has--
there's not a-- one
person has had a legal outcome.
And that is a very
serious commentary
right now in the United States.
There is Michelle Alexander's
"The New Jim Crow"
and then Bryan Stevenson's
"Just Mercy," which is maybe
the most important book
of the last few years,
where they're saying our systems
of handing out punishments
are so deeply power-
and class-biased,
that that's part of the story.
I know if I drive through
in an inappropriate way,
but I'm in the
right car, I'm OK.
They're not going to look
in my glove compartment,
and that's part
of the phenomenon.
Wish I'd written more.
AUDIENCE: Just a quick question.
How do you distinguish
between influence and power?
DACHER KELTNER: That is
not a quick question.
That is one-- that took
me 19 years to figure out.
And I'm sorry you thought
of it in 12 seconds.
So, yeah, there's been
a move that most people
think of our model as
power is influence, right?
But there are other
older approaches.
There are sociological
analyses of power
is just you're
part of the elite.
So if I'm at Google and I
went to the right school
and I'm in this
position of title,
my authority from those
institutions gives me power.
But we move to
influence, because I
wanted to understand
human relationships.
And I also think it
does a fairer job
of thinking about important
social changes in history.
The Silicon Valley
was created by people
who didn't necessarily
have a lot of money.
They went to good schools.
But they did unusual
things that were
risky that changed the world.
So I moved to an
influence model of power.
So they're almost synonymous.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about the impact
of being powerless,
having no power, cortisone
levels and health outcomes.
When people find
themselves in a situation
where they are without
power, what can they do?
What research has
been shown to get
rid of their cortisone
levels, improve
their overall well-being?
DACHER KELTNER: Well, this is
one of the biggest problems,
right?
20% of our kids is in poverty.
Most of our health care
costs, 1/5 of our GDP
is devoted to health
care, are what
are called frequent
flyers, who are
people who are in poverty who
don't have a sense of power.
And so I think the
sense is that A,
a new movement in
the interventions
is about empowerment.
And that's an old idea.
So take kids in the inner city
and turn them into mentors
or turn them into
agents of change.
And then I really take heart
in a lot of the science
that I work in,
which is the really
cheap, soft interventions
that are non-ideological
that will really directly affect
the costs of powerlessness.
So I'm very committed to
promoting getting outdoors,
because we know it has massive
benefits for physical health.
And then there's an ecological
benefit to it as well.
We know-- this will
sound like the Bay Area,
but I'll champion it anywhere--
which is mindfulness is free.
It doesn't have a political
party attached to it.
And now it's spreading
in a lot of contexts.
So I always take this kind
of analysis and think about,
what's an ideal system and how
do we insert those elements
into it that combat these
well-documented effects
of powerlessness?
If I could change the
tax structure, I would.
If I could flow lots of
money into those places,
I would do that, too.
But it's not my bailiwick.
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering if you have
done any research
related to tying
the happiness versus the power?
Is some of the dysfunctional
behavior that we're
seeing from the more
powerful potentially related
to the less happiness,
or is it that they're
looking for some sort of hedonic
thrill or something in the like
there?
DACHER KELTNER:
That's really cool.
It's funny.
I was giving a
talk-- anyway, I'm
starting to merge the power
hierarchy of stuff, poverty,
with happiness.
It's interesting-- and
thanks for taking the class.
We're talking about it with
Jennifer's group later.
It's interesting.
The well-to-do in
the United States
underperform in
terms of happiness.
They're not as happy
as they should be.
Our culture is not as
happy as it could be.
And I think it has to
do with power dynamics.
That people tend to be happier
in more egalitarian cultures.
There are a lot of
new data showing
egalitarian cultures have
better physical health, less
ingroup-outgroup
dynamics and stuff.
So I think that one of the
things that I could have-- this
would be a good "New
York Times" op-ed piece--
is to say, here's how power and
privilege and wealth cost you,
right, which is we show you lose
a little bit of your kindness
toward other people.
And that's one of the most
rewarding things in human life,
right?
When you're on your deathbed--
I always think like this.
And people are like, oh, god.
Where's he going?
I get my Berkeley undergrads--
when you're on your death bed--
and they're like, I
don't like this class.
You're going to be thinking
about the kind things.
And that's what lasts, right?
And privilege and power
deprive you of that,
as one example that
those paradoxes
that we can bring into focus.
And I think the hedonic
treadmill is very true.
We just stop enjoying the
everyday joys and focus
on other things.
Great connection.
SPEAKER 2: I think
we're out of time.
But thank you so much to
Dacher for being here today.
DACHER KELTNER: Go do good.